- 44 jours seulement après avoir
mis les pieds au 10 Downingz z e
à la pression : elle annonce
qu'elle quitte ses fonctions.
La première ministr
démissionne, affirmant qu'elle
n'arrivait pas à mettre en
oeuv Peu après son arrivée
au pouvoir, le ministre
des Finances présentait un plan
qui comportait entre autres
des baisses d'impôts
"Il faut une nouvelle approche",
la valeur de la livre sterling
a chuté, la nqnque d'Angleterre
s'est inquiétée pour
la stabilité financière du pays.
poste, le ministre des Finances
a été poussé à la démission.
Fraîchement noururururururururé
un virage à 180 degrés.
"Cette baisse d'impôt
était une erreur",
a admis Jeremy Hunt.
CATHERINE FIESCHI, fondatrice
et directr m m m m m m m m m m ,
c'était qu'eux savaient gérer
l'économie alors que les
travaillistes ne faisaient que
dépenser. Ça a été difficile
la période COVID évidemment,
mais là, Liz ususs est la preuve
par neuf qu'en fait, ils ne
savent plus gérer l'économie,
clou dans le cercueil.
(rires)
- Puis, il y a eu une série
à la Chambre des communes.
La leaderininininininininininie
Liz Truss, absente de la chambre
lors d'un débat d'urgence,
ne se cache pas sous un bureau.
Et un vote de confiance
mercredi soir, au cours duquel
des dizaines de députés
leur propre gouvernement.
Prise dans la coususion, Liz
Truss elle-même s'est abstenue.
C'C'est honteux et consternant",
a dit cet élu conservateur
d'arrière-ban, ne cachant pas
- I am a fighter
and not a quitter!
- Il y a quelques jours à peine,
Liz Truss affirmait
qu'eàààààààààààààààààààààààààààs
à la démission étaient de plus
en plus nombreux.
en ligne une vidéo comparant
la durée de vie politique
de la première ministre
à celle d'une laitue.d d d d d s
come on ♪
l'opposition travailliste,
qui mène par quelques dizaines
les conservateurs ne peuvent pas
décider entre eux du sort
du pays.
Il faut une élection générale.
Maintenant, Raphaël, on se
En tout cas, il y aura
une cosese à la direction
et ça va être expéditif;
on n'a jamais vu ça.AEAEAEAEAEËR
- Parce qu'on doit connaître,
Céline, les résultats d'ici
vendredi prochain. Les membres
nous dit-on, ainsi que les
députés qui joueront un grand
rôle. Il y a des candidats
qui semble
Parmi les noms qui circulent,
Rishi Sunak, celui qui a per
la course à la direction
contre Liz Truss en septembre,
l'ancien premier ministre,
qui a quitté ses fonctions en
septembre et qui serait, selon
intéressé à présenter
sa candidature
Vous entendiez dans le reportage
le chef travailliste, Céline,out
une élection générale pour
que la population puisse
se présenter, mais on voit bien
le Parti conservateur, c'est
plôôt, donc, une course pour
se choisir un nouveau chef.
Et s'il n'y a pas tétététététét,
bien, la prochaine élection,
elle n'est prévu que pour 2024,
voire le début de 2025.
Donc en attendant,
ce qu'on verra, eh bien, c'est
un cinquième chef, cinquième
à Downing Street depuis que
le Parti conservatr r est
au pouvoir il y a 12 ans.
- Oui, le passage du Liz Truss t
que chaotiques.
Merci beaucoup, Raphaël.
- Merci. Au revoir.